just opened up my book
started reading the first sentence of
the paragraph
when i heard what sounded like freight
train coming through my bedroom
i jumped out of the bed and then there
was a pumping sound that consecutively
got
much faster and with each thumb i felt
the rig
actually shaped
then there was an initial boom the
lights went out
and there was a huge explosion
the explosion rocked the rig about 10
o'clock central time
spraying flames in every direction
[Music]
well i saw fire from derrick lake to
derek
you have oil and gas under pressure
underground that erupts
upward it was extremely loud
it actually started sounding like a
living thing
it's the sound of escaping gas feeding
the fireball incinerating the deepwater
horizon
it's like you're almost waiting to die
there's people screaming
you feel the heat from the fire i'm
scared to death
i figured this is my time i'm gonna die
126 people were on board at the time of
the explosion
some jumped more than 75 feet into the
ocean
the coast guard is pressing its search
today for 11 workers still missing
i started to have a bad feeling when the
sun came up
it got very precarious at that time
time was running out
deepwater horizon a state of the art
semi submersible dynamically positioned
by satellite
drilling rig
and transocean rents deep water horizon
to the big oil companies
at about half a million dollars a day
now what the oil companies use deep
deepwater horizon for us to drill the
wells
they come out they drill in really
challenging environments
they find the oil sometimes they set up
production well
then they go to the next job
it is different than than any other job
a lot of people when they first start
out they they try to compare it to
construction
and it's a completely different thing
being away from your family you know
something happens you can't just leave
it
it's all weather permitting
these are our charts and this is our
tracking of
hurricane ivan let's put a mark on that
piece of paper where wheeze at
everybody out there gets kind of close i
mean as far as friendships and stuff
like that
are you going to do some work now really
i'm with him more than i am my own
family most of the time
all right there's yancy it's a little
different than being home because you
know
and it is dangerous you never know when
cables are gonna break or
the equipment's gonna fail this is our
sub-sea control panel this is used to
shut down
any blowouts that come from the sub-sea
floor
the guys you're working with a lot of
times they do have your life in their
hands
[Laughter]
night was amazingly calm night
very little wind i mean it was just
ideal i just noticed uh mentally that
evening at sunset
how pretty was
[Music]
i was intending to paperwork my mate he
noticed quite a bit of mud falling
through the center of the rig
i stood up to uh see what he was talking
about and i turned around that's when i
noticed the
mud running down so i looked up by the
side window
four sides of the vessel
and i seen the look come out when the
mud from top of
derrick is not good my room phone
rang and
the person at the other end of the line
there
opened up by saying we have a situation
he said we have mud going to the crown
i was just horrified i said well do
y'all have it shut in
he said jason is shutting it in now
and he said randy we need your help and
i'll never forget that
and i said i'll be right there
i contacted the horizon bridge on the
vhf radio
and advised him of the mud coming down
and asking what the situation was
with tension in his voice he immediately
advised me that i was having
trouble with the whale i came up to the
bridge
at that time i felt jolt
when i felt that jolt was a series of
combustible gas alarms that went off
nancy came over and turned the cctv
over to the starboard side and that's
when i witnessed mud
coming from the starboard side
when i woke up i heard like a loud
buzzing
i wasn't sure what it was i just thought
somebody was cleaning or something like
that outside my room so i just fell back
asleep
i heard a hissing noise and
and a thumb within seconds of that
i started hearing beeping and i'm
hearing the bbb but
it's continuous and i'm thinking to
myself okay what what's going on
and i'm trying to put all this together
in my head as to the thumb the hissing
and now the beats
i hear the engine start to rev normal
operating
rpms to way above what i'd ever heard it
run before
and it's continuously steadily rising
and i knew then that we were having a
problem
as i start to push back from my desk the
computer monitor exploded in front of me
all the lights in my shop popped the
light bulbs themselves physically popped
now i know we're in trouble i reach down
to grab my door
and at the simultaneously of grabbing
the handle
the engine goes to a level that is
[Music]
higher than i can even describe it it's
spinning so fast
that
it just it stops spinning
and there's a huge explosion
that explosion blew the fire door that
was between me and those faces
off the hinges it blew me probably
20 feet against a bulkhead against the
wall
and i remember then that the lights went
out
power went out i could hear everything
deathly calm
and i started trying to find my clothes
in the dark
i grabbed my boots put them on
i couldn't see anything i couldn't
breathe there was no oxygen
i crawled across the floor found the
opening
made my way out had a small pin
flashlight in my pocket that i put in my
mouth
to try to see i still couldn't see i
didn't know why i couldn't see i just
couldn't see anything
i made it to the next door by feel
and as i reached the next door i reached
up and grabbed the handle for it
it then exploded
[Music]
my next recollection was
that i had a lot of debris on top of me
i tried two different times to get up
but whatever it was it was a substantial
weight
and i told myself either you get up or
you're gonna
lay here and die
[Music]
dude that was crazy when that [ __ ] blew
the rig flashed out
i went over to the general alarm and hit
the general alarm
yes he made the announcement over the pa
report to emergency stations and
lifeboats and at that point i noticed
that no one had hit any of the distress
buttons
so i went over and hit the distress
buttons and issued a mayday
[Music]
crawling through the ecr
my arm wouldn't work my left leg
wouldn't work
i couldn't breathe i couldn't see i knew
i had to get outside
it's just some fresh air
i crawl across the bodies of at least
two men
i don't know their condition i'm trying
to get them to respond they're not
responding i assume they're dead
and keep moving because i know that i'm
in no condition to help them
i can barely help myself at this point
so i was tripping and falling trying to
make my way
to the outside water type door
i get about halfway across it and i can
actually start to see the light
a dim light so i'm assuming i'm headed
in the right direction i keep going
towards the light
eventually i make my way outside i've
got my bearings got my eyes cleaned out
there was no
walkway there were no handrails and
there was no stairwell left
the wall the handrail the walkway all
those things were missing
they were completely blown off the back
of the rig
one more step and i would have went in
the water
so open my cabin door right leg was hung
on something i don't know what still
but i pulled it as hard as i could and
it came free
[Applause]
i attempted to stand up that was a wrong
thing to do because i immediately
stuck my head into smoke and with the
training that we've all had on the rig i
knew to stay low
i got on my hands and knees so i was
totally disoriented
i'd lost orientation on which way the
doorway was
and i remember just sitting there and
just trying to think which way is it
and then i felt something that felt like
air
and i said to myself that's the
direction i need to go that leaves out
so i had to crawl very slowly because
that
end of the living quarters was pretty
well demolished
debris everywhere but i made it to the
doorway
and what i thought was air was actually
methane
and i could actually feel like droplets
it was moist on the side of my face
i continued to crawl down the hallway
slowly and i put my hand
on the body and it was wyman wheeler
there's two lifeboats there on that like
boat deck
and from what i saw what i heard and
what i felt
i seriously considered launching a light
boat by myself
because i knew that something really
really bad had happened and it
wasn't going to get any better anytime
soon i had an inclination that
this was way worse than anyone could
expect
i thought about it for a second and i
remember that i had i'll have
responsibilities
yeah i have a emergency station to go to
the problem was my emergency station no
longer existed
so i made a decision to put my life
jacket on right there
and try to make my way to the bridge
which would be my secondary muster
station
i determined if i couldn't make it there
i was going to come back and launch the
life boat by myself
i'm on the fire team so i was trying to
get to my fire station
my main fire station is the one in the
back of the rig
[Music]
i could see it and i could see that
nobody was there and there was a bunch
of smoke around it
i turned around to go back to the front
of the rig
[Music]
and that's when i saw the flames of the
derrick
so i saw that i knew there was no way
we're gonna put it out we were just
gonna
get off of there oh sure that's when
my panic set in i mean that scared me
absolutely to death right then
i've never had a feeling like that
it i mean the lifeboats are probably
gone
i didn't know i hadn't seen anybody
until this point i didn't know if i was
the only person still on the rig or what
yeah that's all i kept thinking was well
we're all dead
i was relieved for the night on the way
home received a phone call
they said we just had a oil rig
explosion you need to come back here
as soon as possible five minutes ago so
i said
okay i'm turning around right now
i said just throw my all my gear in the
helicopter
and i'll change in route
just ran right to the helicopter hop in
and off we went
as soon as we took off i put my night
vision goggles down
and i could see this immense glow on the
horizon
it looked like i was flying to new york
city the glow was that immense and
normally
you you might see a faint horizon or you
see no horizon at all
and i i told my crew i said guys you see
that light on the horizon
that's where we're going to it's sunk in
right there that this is
this is real this is the real thing
we don't know what we're going to see
when we get there but we know it's big
the next thing i recollect is i saw
like a beam of light like a flashlight
bouncing
and i saw that to be stan cardin
well about that time jimmy harold
came out of his room
he told me he was in the shower when
explosion happened
managed to find a pair of coveralls and
put
those on i said jimmy i've got wyman
down right here
so we asked him to go to the bow
and get a frecher
we continued to remove this debris off
of wyman
i helped him up and i was going to try
to
help walk him out thinking that that
might be quicker
he made a couple of steps with his arm
around my shoulder
he was in pain and he said
set me down set me down
so we set him back down and
he said y'all go on save yourself
you know and i said no we're not going
to leave you we're not going to leave
you in here
once i got on the bridge i reported
immediately to the captain
that we have no propulsion we have no
power
and i said you need to understand engine
number three for sure
has blown up we need to abandon ship now
i turned around i didn't recognize who
it was at the time
because he was covered in blood it was
mike williams
gpt i asked him what do you mean gone he
said they've blown up
they're all gone they're blown up upon
looking at the screen there was still
nothing no engine starting no thrusters
running nothing we were still dead ship
chris pleasant the subsidy supervisor
was standing at the bop panel
i hollered out to chris pleasant have
you eds
he said he needed permission to eds
somebody
on the bridge hollered out he cannot eds
without the oim's approval
i hollered out can we eds he said yes
eds eds
when i turned back to chris he was in
the panel pushing a button
i hit the eds and uh i seen it go to
close
and i was looking through that panel
trying to see what was going on
after i saw that i had no hydraulics i
had no pressure in the system
that allowed those functions to work
i knew it was time
i hollered to chris i need confirmation
that we have eds
he said yes and he pointed at a light in
the panel
[Music]
steve tony then he turns away and he
said
i'm going to the emergency generator
room like that
and i said you need me to go with you
and
he didn't say nothing but i looked out
that door and i said i ain't gone
when i left the bridge i went to close
the watertight door
and mike williams pushed the door back
and he he said you're not going alone
chief
i said well come on paul meinhard the
motorman
also fell in line and we ran towards the
standby generator
as i was running i looked up at the
derrick and i could see nothing but
flames
because i could see no equipment
whatsoever
it was solid flames
when we walked into the standby
generator room
my thinking at that point was what
remaining fuel would be in the riser it
would burn away
and we were going to need power as well
as fire pumps
i hit the start button there was
absolutely no turning over of the engine
at that point i said that's it let's go
back to the bridge that
it's not going to crank
on our way back to the bridge is when i
noticed i believe it was lifeboat number
one
had descended and was motoring away they
had descended and disconnected from the
rig
the captain yelled and said that we were
abandoning
i went over to the pa and made the last
announcement and said that we were
abandoning the rig
yeah she myself and the captain were the
last to leave the bridge and we went
down
a craft station where there were a few
others
we went down to the live capsule deck
everybody was panicking some people were
trying to stay calm and
and do what needed to be done like the
chief mate
captains that they were trying to get
the stuff handled the way they were
trained and who
had to handle it some people were
jumping off
some people were holding people back
from jumping off they wouldn't let them
and then other people were screaming we
got to get out of here we got to get out
here
so i mean there was a certain level of
panic
that everybody was in it made things a
little more difficult getting all three
i got the number two lifeboat everybody
was in there hollering and screaming you
know we gotta go
with derek's fixing to fall on us they
finally got everybody in there
and shut the door
then they release the lifeboat down to
the water
as we were making our way down the
ladder way to get to the live boats
lifeboat number two descended
so now there are the two forward life
boats are both gone they're both
unavailable once they go down there's no
coming back
up because we had no power
there's several minor explosions
occurring things are falling
you can hear stuff popping
it seemed like an eternity they came
back
with a stretcher we were able to
get wyman on that stretcher when we got
outside of the living quarters the first
thing i observed was
both of the main lipos had already been
deployed and they had left
i also looked to my left and i saw
captain curt and a few of his crew
starting to deploy
a life raft and we continued
down the walkway until we got to that
life raft
and we were able to catch the the head
part of the stretcher
and and assist getting wyman into the
life raft
and i i think we actually fell trying to
you know
get him into the life raft but the main
thing is
wyman was there you know he didn't get
left behind
there was a lot of explosion still going
on
and immense heat all the uh
flames and heat from the rig floor were
coming down the forward part of that
deck as well as all the flames and the
heat from under the rig they were
meeting
i guess like a vortex or something right
there at the life raft
but i can remember feeling the intense
heat on my knees
i also heard screaming we're gonna die
we're gonna die
i honestly thought that we were gonna
cook right there
i wasn't sure that the life raft was
gonna survive there was a crowd of
folks there trying to get into this
small opening
there was so much heat coming up i
thought for sure the life raft was going
to pop or melt
and the people inside were going to cook
moments after the rake first exploded
you can hear the roar
it's the sound of escaping gas feeding
the fireball incinerating the deep water
horizon
we was approximately 100 meters out
my guys instinctively getting the
chips frc ready
i get the command to launch shirley
after we've seen the first
three guys jump off the rig
multiple personnel on water any person
you can help
i knew this was big i've never seen
flames that
gigantic before that huge
this was like seeing hell on earth
the next thing i knew the life raft was
descending when we touched the water
i heard somebody holler out where the
paddles
i jumped out of the life raft chad
murray
jumped out and was right behind me
and grabbed hold of rope on the side of
the life raft and started swimming
trying to pull the life raft away
i was swimming on my side looking up at
the rig
i would say 25 30 feet above me there
was a tremendous amount of smoke
bellowing out from under the rig
i asked captain what about us he said uh
i don't know about you but
i'm going to jump
so he actually jumped first
i waited for a minute because when i
looked over the
life raft was basically right underneath
me
so i waited for a minute and uh
so it could actually move out of the way
and uh i jumped
when i uh resurfaced i had a
life the life raft was like 10 or 15
feet away from me
so i swam to the life raft and i seen
uh captain and a few other guys that
were on the outside life raft
as we're swimming trying to pull this
life raft away from the rig
i got to a point where i could see the
hell of that
i witnessed an individual running at
full speed across the heli deck
when he jumped off the end of the heli
deck he was still running
just before he splashed into the water
he was actually looking over at us
in our training they teach you to reach
your hand around your life jacket
take one step off look straight ahead
cross your legs and fall
the problem with that is there's no life
raft down there at the bottom
maybe 90 feet 100 feet
uh it's a long ways
so i took off running and i jumped
i cleared the life raft by pretty good
ways
once i hit the water when i came back up
i couldn't see anything again
because now we've got a new set of
problems oil
hydraulic fluid gasoline diesel whatever
it is that's floating on the water
is now burning my entire body i'm now
covered in this sludge
i don't know what it is it's burning i
can't hardly breathe
but i could feel the heat from the fire
underneath the vessel
at that point i started backstroking
with the one arm and one leg
that would work until i remember feeling
no pain i remember feeling no heat
and thinking that that was it
i had died
sometime later something i apparently
woke me back
up a pop or explosion something
and i remember feeling the heat again
starting to feel the pain come back
thinking i've got to swim i've got to
swim and i started swimming again
and i heard something in the distance i
heard over here over here
i was thinking to myself what in the
world can that be
whatever it is i'm gonna go to it and
just started swimming as hard as i could
to get to it
and then i felt something start lifting
me out of the water
a small orange rescue craft
had grabbed me and flipped me over into
the boat
at that point guys there's a raft in the
water
we proceeded to go towards the rig
now we're close enough that i can feel
the heat i'm starting to feel the heat
again
and i see the life raft and it's
literally
still under the rig and i can see people
outside of it
we get up to them throw them a line they
get tied on
then the fast rescue boat pulled us to
the starboard side of the bankston
[Music]
the banks and crew was throwing down
jacob's ladders
to the lifeboats to where people inside
can get up on deck
[Music]
i seen carl the raid operator he was
taking muster
asked them how many people we were
missing
come to find out it was 11.
dude
we're flying as close as to a half mile
to a quarter
mile circling the rig looking for
survivors in the water
we smelled the smoke we smelled the oil
the fumes
we felt the heat through the cockpit we
felt it in the helicopter
you know through the windshields it
really hits home and strikes you that
hey
we're flying at 300 feet and the flames
are
higher than we are probably up to 500
feet
i was looking into this burning hulk of
metal
and it was like looking into the face of
the devil
it was it was like a living thing
they already had both that were putting
water
on the rig i don't know where they came
from they came out the woodwork they
were
there in no time
the coast guard helicopters were flying
around
we were hovering about half a mile to
the east
of the burning rig initially we got the
word that
we were to pick up a critically wounded
victim so then we lowered our
rescue swimmer to the damon bankston
moving out somewhere swimming outside
the rescue swimmer he's basically our
paramedic
he's our assigned emt's so he's the guy
who knows the first aid
oh man roger hold position i'm gonna
bring him down
the rail it's halfway down
forward and right 40.
when the coast guard arrived the rescue
swimmer
he came in and he asked who's the
critical
buddy treyan was the worst at that point
they brought in a gurney i stepped to
the back side of the bed to assist
from getting buddy on the gurney as i
rolled him he was screaming and
hollering at his leg was hurt
real bad he had a severe laceration on
his
leg he also had a twisted and mangled
lower calf his fingernails were gone
he had a hole in the side of his neck
and i looked back
and buddy's back was burnt
from uh belt to head
once we got him on the gurney they took
him out
[Music]
we went to carry him out after we
strapped him in
and the supply boat was full of big
containers
so you really have no clear path to the
back of the boat
so we're like yeah are we going to get
this guy out
we actually had to lift him up over
these
containers and got him hoisted up to the
helicopter
it's hard when you're departing a scene
like that
to to know that there's still 11 people
missing
our mission was to return to base with a
critically injured victim but it still
felt bad
to lead the scene but that was the
tasking we were given
it began with a powerful explosion a
column of flames shooting into the night
sky over the gulf of mexico
the oil rig's still burning and could
topple into the water at any moment
the source of that fire is predominantly
coming from the wellhead itself it's
crude oil
that is leaching from this wellhead and
as long as that crude is leaching we're
going to continue to see
that fire
after two helicopters left i mean it was
like uh with uh
wounded everything just kind of fell in
place
finally able to you know start calming
down
and we sat there pretty much watched the
rig burn for six or seven hours
there's something i'll never forget the
images
just burn in my head i'll never forget
knowing that after we took the mustard
and stuff we figured out you know we
were missing
11 guys you know most of we assumed they
were
they were on the rig we didn't know and
that was
that's pretty tough not knowing
i went home that morning turn on the
news and then you find out
well there's still 11 people missing
it's like oh
it's like man i hope they made it i just
hope they made it off
in the news the coast guard is pressing
its search today for 11 workers still
missing on a burning oil drilling
platform off the coast of louisiana
fire boats are struggling to put out
flames triggered by the explosion on
tuesday night
and we left from the rig we rode for
probably a good four hours to another
platform
the guys on that platform they sent down
a bag with some cigarettes and
some snuff in it stuff and some clothes
the survivors who were not injured are
now making their way to shore they will
be arriving here in port later this
evening
the search for the missing will continue
through the night
a pair of coast guard cutters stayed out
in the gulf all night looking for these
missing workers
they will be joined a little bit later
by in one of these choppers which is set
to leave at first light here and as you
can imagine the longer the search and
rescue mission goes without resolution
the more fear and concern
[Music]
when grow got off the boat and they
brought around three or four
prepaid cell phones or passing those
around everybody was
you know passing talking to their family
for about 30 seconds only just letting
them know they were
off the boat that was the first time i
got to talk to my wife
from there we rode to new orleans to the
crown plaza
we went in the back of it because they
told us there was so many lawyers and
media out front they were making us go
in the back
and all their families were waiting
that was the first time i got to see my
wife
she ran up smiling and then
by the time she got her arms around my
neck she was burst out in tears
both of us did
we were on site about midnight so we
were only on site
in a relatively short period of time i
started to have a bad feeling
when the sun came up and we could get a
more accurate assessment of the extent
of the damage on board the oil rig
you could see the derrick leaning over
on the crane and you could actually see
what used to be incredibly stout steel
and sagging
like a clothesline it got very
precarious at that time
and we were all very very concerned
that uh time was running out
but at around 10 o'clock we could see
the half star recorder starting to
slowly drop into the sea
the loud groans was coming out of this
vessel as she broke up
was becoming much more pronounced we
started to back off
[Music]
a thick sheen of brown emulsified oil
still on fire behind
i think unfortunately for us we were
fighting a losing battle from the start
but you still feel a tremendous loss you
still feel a tremendous sense of failure
my thinking immediately shifted
to that of the people on board
you're there to help the the loved ones
of those people that
may be missing come to some
sense of closure it was uh
quite a silence on the ridge and i know
we were all thinking the same thing
you you feel the loss
uh you feel the failure you feel it deep
and uh it settles in more and more as
time goes by
and as adrenaline subsides yeah
you know i i'm still going over things
in my mind
there were 126 crew members on board the
rig
11 of the workers never had a chance
they were killed in the explosion
their bodies never recovered
these guys on the deep water are the
fighter pilots
of our profession they are the rock
stars
only the very best of the best
work on the deep water and they don't
accept anything less
[Music]
[Music]
the horizon was an exemplary rig with
excellent personnel they paid the
ultimate
price they gave their life to try to
minimize the damage
that was done to people property
environment
and i hope at least that message is
clear
that they pay the ultimate price
[Music]
you